then after zucca muhammad a man on 28
zimmerman says if you're looking for a
midsize car with cutting-edge technology
and great design try the infiniti q50 it
was first launched on the market back in
2013 so it's not exactly new but the
infiniti q50 is still a real head turner
and it's surprisingly quiet that's
thanks to the hybrid drive
but the infiniti q50 has more surprises
to offer that definitely set it apart
from its rivals one of the larger and
more noticeable ones can be found inside
I trinath the time in a nice detail in
the cabin is that you have two screens
the top one is reserved for either the
around view camera system or the GPS but
then below you can still see say how
much feel you are using thoughts them
not survive pretty football staton
on-site nothing when it comes to the
exterior the shape may not stand out so
much but the lines are sleek and then
there's those sickle-shaped LED
headlights the unmistakable gaze as
infinity calls it that certainly give
the car presence and radiates a raw
power not something you necessarily
expect from a fuel economic hybrid
the same signature lights also grace the
rear the capacity of the trunk is
limited just 300 litres that's
definitely a weakness in the Japanese
car compared with its European rivals
the hybrid drive is noticeably sporting
designed above all for speed a high
performer that's certainly enjoyable to
drive space may be lacking in the truck
but the Infinity makes up for it in the
cabin with a generous amount of space
for passengers the q50 comes with three
drivers that are sold on the European
market there's the diesel and petrol
engines and then there's the gasoline
hybrid version which is the one we're
testing
it offers 268 kilowatts and can power
from 0 to 100 kilometers an hour in just
5.1 seconds thanks to the electric motor
top speed is 250 kilometers an hour and
fuel economy six point two liters okay
one thing Andre likes is the metal shift
pedals on the q50 the only drawback is
that they have plastic finishing that's
quite sharp on the edges to light our
shafa come come the q50 has three
different drive settings standard sport
and eco and that's not all you can also
choose your own settings in ninety six
different categories allowing the car to
be tailored to the individual needs of
the driver him to equal those who find
the eco setting a little too tame can
switch to sports mode the q50 then
sounds really good and it certainly
moves the steering also becomes tighter
and more direct for Andre's taste it's a
little too tight but even then there's a
solution you can select individual mode
and adjust the settings to what you want
individual models the commands I also
understand we mustn't it's not
the interior feels luxurious and
inviting the double screen center
console is the definite highlight the
infotainment system is operated by
touchpad or if you prefer by voice
command the multifunctional steering
wheel includes cruise control as
standard for the first time the leather
appointed upholstery also helps to give
a high quality feel the letter Q plays
an important role in infinities
philosophy the first infinity model was
the q45 the q50 was designed to hail the
start of a new distinctly sporty series
they prefer the q50 is pretty chic but
infinity is not doing so well in Germany
first there's the high starting price
around fifty three thousand euros for
the hybrid version compared with a
plug-in hybrid like the Passat GTE that
goes for just forty four thousand even
worse Germany currently has only six
dealers who offer infinity unbeaten so
the q50 has plenty to offer but if
infinity really wants to power ahead in
Europe a few changes may be needed